it's funny that seems to be the story
that people are focusing on but you know
that was a very minor part of it for me
we we the bigger story to me is the fact
that the entire episode takes place on
Clare's computer screen I find that to
be the most interesting part of this but
yeah we we just wanted to do it in there
in a way that seemed as real as possible
so we just use the devices that one
would use in real life picking up a
device is really easy to do and
connecting with someone across the
country is extremely simple now with all
the technology we have I have a feeling
though that producing this episode and
directing it may not have been so simple
what sort of challenges did you run into
yeah there are there was a lot that went
into this first of all the hardest part
was coming up with the storyline in
which we could feature all 11 or 12 of
our actors and still stay on one
person's computer screen once we had the
original idea for the story things
really fell into place quickly and the
problem wasn't so much of how we gonna
fit every I mean how are we going to
feature everybody but how are we going
to fit all this into one episode and
then originally we're going to have the
actors shoot themselves by holding up
the camera like one would do the phone
like one would do in real life but then
there are other considerations about
framing things properly and not shooting
off the set so we quickly devised the
method where the cameraman we use the
camera or camera people to shoot them
with the phones and then so it didn't
look like the phones were floating out
in space the actors were instructed to
always keep their hands on the cameraman
tan and and and that's how we did it was
a very very romantic day was there any
product placement involved did they pay
for any of this Apple no other than
providing the other than providing the
products that we used for the episode no
they were this was done you know this is
purely a creative decision on our part
just like the iPad episode was you know
I happen to be very techy and I like
this stuff
so in the last episode we just needed a
reason for Phil to be waiting in line
and it just so happened to line up when
with when the ipad was coming out so it
was a natural fit and here once again
this just came from my life I mean I was
facetiming with my daughter at college
and I was looking at my screen and there
was some emails and a script I was
working on and I could see her and I
could also see myself and my wife
standing behind me and some web page is
open and I thought wow this really
paints an amazing picture of my life you
can tell a lot about me from this one
screen and that's where the ideas
started so this is not the first time
you've featured Apple devices in your
show and we see the vices on television
all the time but we don't necessarily
think about the collaboration between
the technology company and the
television studio how important is that
relationship well listen you wanna it's
a it's a fine line because we're not
here to sell apple products and I mean
that's not our goal in terms of this
episode they may advertise with us and
that's wonderful and I know Steve Jobs
was a big modern family fan and that was
very meaningful to me and I know that
many of the people at Apple are fans of
the show and and we're very big fans of
their products so you know really this
is much more of a personal interaction
than it is a business relationship how
impressive are these cameras that can
capture an entire episode on television
now yeah I think the smart phones today
and not just apples but you know other
other companies cameras on their phones
are amazing and most viewers would be
hard-pressed to tell a difference we've
actually snuck in some footage from
iPhones in the past in our episodes just
because we needed a quick shot and it's
pretty hard to tell the difference so
it's amazing it's it so it opens up a
whole new world for amateur filmmakers
and budding filmmakers people who are
just beginning because you don't need
that initial huge investment anymore you
can make a compelling movie on your
phone and your computer you know and all
you really need is a great story and
some great characters and and off you go